festnahmen und neue erkenntnisse im
wirecard skandal die bilanzen sollen
seit fünf jahren systematisch gefälscht
worden seien sagen die ermittler
diskussion über corona regeln für
urlaubsrückkehrer wer aus einem
risikogebiet nach hause kommt muss
künftig mit tests rechnen und positive
bilanz in sachen home office es gibt
weniger stress die produktivität steigt
aber der kontakt zu den kollegen fehlt
zeigt eine studie
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wir auch norbert lehmann
für den sport eine schöne neue form der
skandal um den finanzdienstleister
wirecard nimmt immer größere dimensionen
an
die staatsanwaltschaft spricht von
gewerbsmäßigem bandenbetrug offenbar
wurden schon seit fünf jahren verluste
verschleiert investoren und banken um
milliarden betrogen gegen ehemalige
vorstände wurden heute haftbefehle
erlassen einer ist noch auf der flucht
und auch die bundesregierung gerät
zunehmend in erklärungsnot
alexander pohl er war schon auf freiem
fuß jetzt muss der frühere wirecard chef
markus braun
doch ins gefängnis zusammen mit zwei
seiner ehemaligen vorstandskollegen
die staatsanwaltschaft wirft den
früheren managern vor die geschäfte des
unternehmens künstlich aufgebläht zu
haben und spricht von gewerbsmäßigem
bandenbetrug in wirklichkeit war den
beschuldigten spätestens seit ende 2015
klar dass der weltkonzern mit den
tatsächlichen geschäften insgesamt
verluste erzielte im juni hatte wirecard
insolvenz angemeldet nachdem knapp zwei
milliarden euro aus den bilanzen
verschwunden waren
vor allem das asien-geschäft geriet in
den fokus mit ihm der zwielichtige
vertriebsvorstand jan marschalek der
sich wohl in russland aufhält und mit
haftbefehl gesucht wird
er soll das betrugssystem aus
scheingeschäften mit aufgebaut haben
abgesegnet von ganz oben
das unternehmen sollte finanzkräftige
erscheinen für investoren und kunden
dadurch attraktiver und so wollte man
dann eben regelmäßig kredite von banken
und sonstigen investoren erlangen diese
stellten wirecard gelder in höhe von
insgesamt 3,2 milliarden euro bereit
summen die auf grund der insolvenz wohl
verloren sind doch nicht nur
großinvestoren haben auf sand gebaut
tausende wirecard aktionäre stehen mit
ihren verlusten alleine da
aktionärsschützer sprechen vom versagen
der aufsichtsbehörde bafin
wir haben ja doch geglaubt es ist ein
dax unternehmen das eine tolle
performance hat aber nach dem
geschäftsmodell das die wirecard am
schluss hatte hätte die bafin ihre
prüfung in meiner ansicht nach ausdehnen
müssen auf das gesamtunternehmen und da
auch tiefer in die in die tiefe gehen
müssen
am kommenden mittwoch wird sich der
finanzausschuss des bundestages mit dem
fall befassen
vor allem mit der frage was die politik
von all dem wusste fragen wir nach bei
unserer pausen expertin und unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondenten zunächst an
die börse zu sehen am main netz was sagt
das über den finanzplatz deutschland aus
wenn eines der vorzeige dax unternehmen
so lange betrieben kann ohne dass jemand
einschreitet schlichtweg das ist
schockierend dieser skandal der sich ja
inzwischen rund um den globus erstreckt
erschüttert das vertrauen in die
aufsichtsbehörden und den wertpapiere
obwohl gerade sie ja in nullzins zeiten
gute rendite bringen können offenbar
wurden ja bei wirecard seit fünf jahren
bilanzen geschönt deren veröffentlichung
mehrfach verschoben und umsätze
aufgebläht milliarden euro wurden
verbrannt
auch investoren darunter auch viele
erfahrene profis haben sich täuschen
lassen
wirecard ist in der königsklasse der
deutschen börse dem dax angesiedelt und
verdrängte dort einst die commerzbank
als firma die ihr geld vor allem als
bezahldienstleister der online porno und
casino industrie verdient hat ein
aufsteiger mit schmuddel image und jetzt
wurde aus schmuddel-image handfester
betrug am anleger und anrufe des
deutschen aktienmarktes auch für die
bundesregierung wird der fall immer
unangenehmer theo koll welche kontakte
gab es zwischen wirecard und dem
kanzleramt und offensichtlich mehr als
bisher bekannt selbst der ehemalige
geheimdienstkoordinator fritzsche hat
sich offensichtlich als bezahlter
türöffner betätigte und für wirecard
einen termin im kanzleramt gemacht
genauso wie wir vorher schon
ex-verteidigungsminister zu guttenberg
mit dem ergebnis dass sich dann die
kanzlerin auf einer china-reise für das
unternehmen stark gemacht hat es ist
aber das muss man dazu sagen an sich ja
nicht ungewöhnlich dass sich für
deutsche firmen im ausland stark
eingesetzt wird in diesem fall aber
stellt sich die frage wer hat wann in
der politik was gewusst und wurde auch
richtig
reagiert das kanzleramt war
offensichtlich schon vor der reise über
schwerwiegende unregelmäßigkeiten
informiert worden und das
finanzministerium waren nochmal deutlich
länger im bilde
so wie es jetzt aussieht hat wirecard
für die bundesregierung das zeug zu
einem ordentlichen debakel dankeschön
für diese informationen und
einschätzungen aus berlin und frankfurt
aufgeblähten bilanzen also bei wirecard
seit 2005 zehn weitere informationen und
hintergründe zu den finanzskandal finden
sie auch online und in unserer zdf heute
app wie lässt sich verhindern dass
urlaubsrückkehrer eine zweite corona
welle auslösen darüber haben heute die
gesundheitsminister von bund und ländern
beraten das ziel mehr heimkehren sollen
sich testen lassen
schauen wir auf europa das sind die
offiziellen krone risikogebiete
luxemburg mehrere balkanstaaten oder die
türkei und auch die urlaubs auch in
urlaubsländern die derzeit nicht als
risikogebiet geltend zeit steigen die
virus fallzahlen etwa in kroatien oder
spanien peter böhme berichtet tests für
reiserückkehrer am flughafen wie am köln
bonn airport die johanniter testen im
auftrag der stadt seit dem auftakt am
samstag kamen 260 urlauber aus freien
stücken zahlten 90 euro
in zukunft könnten solche tests bei
risikogebieten verpflichtend und wohl
auf kassenkosten sein die
gesundheitsminister berieten am
nachmittag
es ist so dass wir uns einig sind in dem
ziel das eben auch es wichtig ist
reiserückkehrer
besonders im blick zu haben sei es auch
dass man vielleicht verstärktes testen
anbietet aber wir haben uns heute noch
nicht inhaltliche komplette geeinigt
das problem ist schon da der
beschauliche bodenseekreis etwa im
kronauer focus mehrere krankheitsfälle
sind auch serbien rückkehrer
zurückzuführen die nicht in quarantäne
gingen ein mädchen steckte sich an das
dann mitschüler ansteckte mehrere
schulen sind betroffen
und auch in hamm besorgnis 16 corona
infizierte davon sieben
urlaubsrückkehrer der oberbürgermeister
wendet sich in einer deutlichen
videobotschaft an seine bürger
ich möchte sie bitten wenn sie in
risikogebiete fahren zum beispiel nach
bosnien in die türkei in die vereinigten
staaten
dann halten sie sich bitte dringend an
die vorgegebenen regeln
das heißt wenn sie zurückkommen müssen
sie automatisch 14 tage in quarantäne
es sei denn man kann einen negativen
test vorweisen
bei den reisenden ist das thema bekannt
flughafen düsseldorf heute mittag ein
flieger aus istanbul
wir haben
ja im anerkannten krankenhaus haben wir
das machen lassen
ich hab den gemacht wir natürlich
negativ die frage ist ob durch
rückkehrer eine zweite quelle drohen
könnte nein das sich momentan nicht
unser gesundheitssystem ist gut
aufgestellt natürlich muss man immer
sehen die viele infektionen dann
angebracht wenn das natürlich mehrere
hunderte oder sogar tausende ist das
natürlich problematisch
corona und der urlaub am freitag wollen
die gesundheitsminister erneut tagen und
wohl auch härtere regeln beschließen
zum großen eu corona rettungspaket
nachdem die staats- und regierungschefs
das 1,8 millionen schwere finanzpaket
geschnürt haben
kommt jetzt deutliche kritik aus dem
europaparlament das werde den geplanten
haushalt so nicht akzeptieren sagte
parlamentspräsident soli und forderte
nachbesserungen bei den beschlossenen
kürzungen stefan leifert in brüssel muss
man damit rechnen dass das eu-parlament
diesen so mühsam ausgehandelten
kompromiss ablehnen
also die macht dazu hätte das parlament
es muss nämlich zustimmen und der unmut
der ist wirklich riesig morgen wird hier
mit überwältigender mehrheit eine
resolution beschlossen werden in der
wirklich jeder der gipfelbeschlüsse den
die staats und regierungschefs hier
gefasst haben
in der luft nur so zerrissen wird der
unmut der ist groß auf der einen seite
auf der anderen seite steckt das
parlament aber in einem dilemma denn
wenn es den eu-haushalt ablehnt dann
auch den corona hilfsfonds dh die
hilfsgelder die würden nicht so schnell
fließen können
auf die vor allem der süden europas ja
so dringend wartet und diesen vorwurf
will sich das parlament nicht aussetzen
deswegen ist das wahrscheinlichste
szenario dass man die nächsten wochen
nutzen wird um noch einmal
nachzuverhandeln
zum beispiel mehr geld für den
klimaschutz mehr geld für
digitalisierung vielleicht auch eine
anschaffung noch mal in sachen
rechtsstaatlichkeit prognose deswegen
nachverhandlungen den sommer über
zustimmung dann im herbst damit sowohl
der haushalt als auch der korona
hilfsfond pünktlich und wie geplant zum
ersten januar nächsten jahres in kraft
treten
dankeschön noch poster stefan leifert
eines der großen streitthemen europas
ist und bleibt auch die illegale
migration innenminister seehofer sprach
heute mit einigen seiner kollegen in
wien
darüber dass wieder vermehrt menschen
unerlaubt über die balkanroute kommen
seit januar sind tausende richtung
deutschland geflohen die meisten anfang
des jahres dann kamen weniger auch wegen
corona doch jetzt werden es wieder mehr
viele stranden in provisorischen lagern
die im bosnischen veli kavlak von dort
berichtet wolf christian ullrich eine
verlassene fabrikhallen ganz im norden
von bosnien hier haben sie ihre zelte
aufgeschlagen weil die offiziellen camps
längst überfüllt sind eine gruppe aus
algerien auf sich allein gestellt wartet
auf die nächste gelegenheit um nach
kroatien zu kommen und damit in die eu
vier mal hat es der 22-jährige sammer
schon versucht die kroatische polizei
hat uns geschlagen
es ist schwierig ich glaube wir
versuchen es in den nächsten tagen
wieder die meisten flüchtlinge und
migranten die durch bosnien ziehen
stranden hierbei villiger klar dusche an
der grenze zu kroatien
dies ist der grüne grenzstreifen
kroatien lässt hier kilometerlang wälder
abholzen für den besseren überblick um
die eu außengrenzen besser zu schützen
und 6000 migranten harren hier deshalb
aus meist monatelang nicht nur in den
fünf flüchtlingslagern im umkreis auch
auf den straßen und das sorgt im ort für
konflikte wir haben einfach nicht
genügend kapazitäten für unsere aufgaben
entweder bosnien hilft oder es gibt
unterstützung von der eu man wird sehen
genau das ist heute in wien thema bei
einer innenministerkonferenz zur
migration auf dem westbalkan die
hoffnung von bundesinnenminister
seehofer dass diejenigen eu staaten die
keine flüchtlinge aufnehmen wollen sie
stattdessen anders engagieren wenn
einzelne staaten eine eine andere
möglichkeit sehen solidarität zu zeigen
dann sollen sie das uns ganz konkret
benennen von polizeikräften oder
schlicht finanzielle unterstützung sei
die rede
in velika klar durch jedenfalls wird auf
allen seiten hilfe benötigt
das verhältnis zwischen washington und
peking ist ohnehin schon schlecht jetzt
gibt es neue spannungen die us-regierung
hat das chinesische konsulat in houston
texas schließen lassen
die diplomaten müssen das land verlassen
sie hätten spioniert und us bürger
beeinflusst erklärte das amerikanische
außenministerium diese bilder sollen
zeigen wie im konsulat akten verbrannt
werden peking reagierte empört auf die
schließung und drohte mit gegenmaßnahmen
wir bleiben in den usa denn präsident
tom hat eine ziemliche kehrtwende in
sachen corona vollzogen
zum ersten mal rief die bürger dazu auf
schutzmasken zu tragen
offen ist ob sein sinneswandel mit den
steigenden infektionszahlen zu tun hat
oder mit seinen sinkenden umfragewerten
aus washington ist raus er kommt ohne
wissenschaftliche experten aber mit
maske resident trumps umfragewerte sind
im keller
nun flucht nach vorn er will wieder
regelmäßig presse briefings geben und
nach monatelangem kleinreden des virus
schlägt er realistischere töne an
es wird leider wohl erst mal schlimmer
werden bevor es besser wird ich sage das
nicht gerne über dinge aber so ist es
auf nachfrage plädiert trump für das
tragen von masken er der das bislang
zwischen den zeilen immer als zeichen
von feigheit abgetan hat ich habe die
maske gleich hier ich trage sie bei mir
ich nutze sie sehr gern kein problem
wenn sie können setzen sie eine maske
auf erst recht wenn sie nahe zueinander
sind bereits zuvor hatte er getwittert
es ist patriotisch eine maske zu tragen
und es gibt niemand der patriotischer
ist als ich doch gesehen wurde er kurz
darauf auf einem dinner erneut ohne
maske glaubwürdig ist ramms neuer
tonfall nicht eher pflichtschuldig hat
er sein statement vorgetragen und eine
strategie was zu tun ist hat er nach wie
vor nicht eher unwahrscheinlich dass er
vom schnellen hochfahren der wirtschaft
abrücken wird könnte das doch als
eingeständnis gewertet werden dass sein
bisheriger weg falsch war
sie demonstrieren für eine masken
pflicht und ein vorsichtigeres öffnen
der wirtschaft erinnerung an 160 an
corona verstorbene pfleger und
krankenschwestern mahnung und kritik am
weg den die usa bislang eingeschlagen
haben
nach deutschland was es bedeutet arm zu
sein erleben hierzulande rund 2,8
millionen kinder und jugendliche laut
einer studie der bertelsmann-stiftung
wächst jedes fünfte kind in armut auf
und die korona krise trifft diese kinder
besonders hart denn ihre eltern
arbeiteten häufig in teilzeit oder als
mini jobber und verloren als erste ihre
jobs heißt es in der studie
aktuell sieht die korona lage in
deutschland so aus die zahl der
neuinfektionen steigt leicht an im
schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 470 menschen
infiziert gestern lag der durchschnitt
noch bei 450 millionen deutsche hat die
korona krise ins home office gezwungen
und jetzt wollen die allermeisten nicht
mehr jeden tag zurück ins büro
das zeigt eine bundesweite
repräsentative studie der krankenkasse
dak
drei viertel aller befragten wollen auch
künftig zumindest teilweise von zu hause
aus arbeiten
denn hier haben sie weniger stress mehr
zeit für die familie und sind sogar
produktiver markus groß berichtet laptop
und kopfhörer mehr braucht jonas ob man
nicht schon vor der korona krise war er
gelegentlich im home-office seit märz
erledigt jetzt eine komplette arbeit für
einen digitalen ferienhausvermittler nun
in den eigenen vier wänden
für mich persönlich ist der größte
vorteil der ersparte arbeitsweg und die
geteilte aufmerksamkeit wildes kind das
größte plus ist vor allem die
vereinbarkeit für mich von arbeit und
familie
so sehen es viele der befragten in der
studie
weitere vorteil flexiblere arbeitszeiten
eine höhere produktivität weil man sich
besser auf die arbeit konzentrieren kann
in der kroner krise mussten viele ins
home office umziehen
waren es in vor pandemie zeiten erst 18
so arbeiten nun fast 40 prozent der
befragten von zu hause aus inzwischen
wollen viele
gar nicht mehr zurück ins büro alles in
allem wird die digitalisierung als
stärker als nutzen wahrgenommen
insgesamt sehen wir keine größeren
gesundheitlichen schwierigkeiten durch
mehr schlafprobleme mehr stress
allerdings fehlt der studie zufolge fast
75 prozent der befragten der direkte
kontakt zu den kollegen
jeder zweite im home-office vermisst
eine klare trennung zwischen arbeit und
berufsleben deshalb ist es wichtig dass
nachhaltige home office konzepte
entwickelt werden die mit einem
betrieblichen gesundheitsmanagement
dafür sorgen dass eine solche balance
zwischen arbeitszeit und freizeit
möglich wird jonas ob man hat sich mit
dem home office arrangiert das büro
vermisst ihr trotzdem hin und wieder für
uns das home-office keine alternative
für die fußballer auch nicht da wird
jetzt in der bundesliga wieder trainiert
ja genau
heute ist rb leipzig als erster verein
ins mannschaftstraining eingestiegen
denn die sachsen haben ja so wie die
bayern das champions league final
turnier in lissabon vor der brust und
treffen am 13 august im viertelfinale
auf atletico madrid
so langsam aber sicher beginnt sie die
heiße phase auch bei rb leipzig die
bundesliga seit fast einem monat beendet
die königsklasse aber die haben sie noch
vor der brust
und da geht es nach kurzer pause wieder
an einem strang zu ziehen
richtig bock zu trainieren haben auch
gut trainiert waren sehr frisch finde
ich sehr lebendig und guten eindruck
gemacht
natürlich jetzt noch nicht jeder pass
dann immer den richtigen abnehmer
gefunden aber trotzdem war das ein sehr
guter trainingsauftakt bis ließ aber und
ist ja noch ein bisschen zeit da wird
das viertelfinale ausgespielt nur eine
partie gegen atletico madrid
verzichten muss er dabei auf torjäger
timo werner der ist ja vorzeitig zu
chelsea gewechselt für 53 millionen euro
der kader von leipzig ist noch nicht
komplett einige sind angeschlagen oder
kommen noch die erste gemeinsame einheit
auf dem rasen also nur ein lockerer
auftakt der ironman 2020 auf hawaii
fällt nun endgültig ins wasser und damit
der korona krise zum opfer
die langstrecken wm entry athlon war
zunächst von oktober auf februar 2000
21 verschoben worden ja jetzt musste der
almen erstmals in seiner 43 jährigen
geschichte abgesagt werden den
wichtigsten triathlon der welt haben bei
den herren seit 2014 ausschließlich
deutsche gewonnen die vorjahresgewinner
jan frodeno und bei den frauen an der
haut müssen nun ein weiteres jahr auf
die chance zur titelverteidigung war das
ist ja werden auch richtig traurig sein
im januar fehlen noch die lottozahlen
die gewinnzahlen lauten 6 11 17 24 25 44
und die superzahl 1 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 5 157 gewitter viele
wolken aber auch sonnenschein stehen
morgen an unwetterwarnungen wegen
gewittern gibt es zurzeit für bayern
mehr dazu hat gleich ist
christian sievers freut sich auf sie um
viertel vor zehn im heute-journal und
wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen ihr
informationsbedürfnis wieder bei
unterstellen einen schönen abend ihnen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter über der mitte
deutschlands star breitet sich ein hoch
aus und so wird es ruhiger
nach norden und nach süden ist ein
bisschen mehr los mit regen und
einzelnen gewittern an den alpen der
nacht brechen die gewitter an den alpen
in sich zusammen ansonsten im norden
kompakte wolken in der mitte klart es
auf und die temperaturen sinken auf 7
grad im hessischen bergland und 15 grad
an den alpen morgen im tagesverlauf im
norden mehr wolken als zum beispiel in
der mitte und es regnet etwas an der
nordsee und dieser regen kann sich
durchaus bis zur ems durchsetzen
an den alpen bilden sich dann gewitter
temperaturen erreichen bis zu 29 grad im
südwesten deutschlands häufig werte über
der 20 grad marke
18 sind es in schleswig holstein dort
wird es am kühlsten seien die nächsten
tage am freitag von westen her schauer
und gewitter ist ziemlich ungemütlich 28
grad werden erreicht am samstag ist es
erst einmal ruhiger und sonntag kommen
dann kräftige schauer und gewitter von
westen auf es wird ziemlich ungemütlich
aber die temperaturen ändern sich kaum
damit ein schöner abend